do I have to pick one
hi glamor I'm America Ferreira and I'm
playing Actor versus character America
clap back Gloria probably rise above
Gloria Barbie pink America
black
I think Gloria and America would more
often go for the Birkenstocks Growing Up
America books Gloria Barbies
um do I have to pick one
Gloria's favorite Barbie is
stereotypical Barbie I do think that if
Isa Rae was a president Barbie when
America was growing up then America
would have picked president Barbie both
Gloria loves both and America loves both
Gloria and America meditation
Gloria weekend with the girls she needs
it America needs a weekend with the bow
Gloria rollerblading America running
Gloria and America would pick the Real
Worlds